this is something we need to address we
have an associate producer
on our show um wow people got a problem
with associates
now i'm seeing a lot of this
you're not gonna bring him up are you
we have an associate producer on our
show by the name of jordan schlansky
yeah yeah he uh yeah he's kind of like
your brother yeah
joke's kind of funny until later on when
anyway this guy has worked for me for 26
years
and i'm honest with you i'm being so
honest with you i still have no idea
what he does for my show
i've asked his direct superiors i've
asked the people who work
under him no one can say exactly what he
do you know what he does
i don't no no one and really seriously
we talk about it yeah
like do you know like there's somebody's
gotta know someone's gotta know no one
really knows what he does no one knows
why he's here at our show um and uh it's
he's become kind of a legend and
everywhere i go people i can go anywhere
in the world and people ask about jordan
uh anyway we wanted to revisit a fun
moment here's a remote we shot with
jordan back in 2013
when this is all real i caught him i
heard he was coming into la
to work late and i caught him coming in
late to work and we managed to get it
all on camera take a look
i'm sitting in the office of jordan
schlansky he's an associate producer at
the show
and uh it's come to my attention
recently
that on fridays for some reason
he doesn't come in until very late uh it
is now
12 20. no jordan schlansky
so i'm sitting and i'm waiting for him
because i want to get to the bottom
of what the jordan does every friday
[Applause]
he's got a kaiser roll in a bag olive
oil
his own mini specialized
pepper grinder
look at this it's got a giant thing of
clorox wipes
now does this look like the office of
someone who's afraid of germs
aloe fresh hydrating gel
espresso cups
he's got two in case he ever makes a
[Laughter]
friend
it's got the death squad commander in
its box
and a backup
why would you why would you have two
you're supposed to go to a children's
hospital
and he's hiding them in his office oh my
god
i'm curious
oh of course cufflinks
for his wedding day
[Applause]
i better put these back i'm sure these
are insured
by lloyds of london if anyone ever wants
to get jordan a wedding present
i believe he's registered at toys r us
[Music]
that's your reaction you just walk into
your office
it feels like an acceptable reaction to
me
jordan do you know what time it is 12
30.
actually it's 12 50.
it's come to my attention that you like
to drift in late on fridays
okay well i work later on fridays than a
lot of people
and i feel like i'm able to adequately
accomplish what i need to in the time
that i'm here
i've uh prepared my daily task ahead of
me already
your daily task what's your daily task
to pour olive oil onto a kaiser roll
daily task let me ask you uh jordan what
you were doing this morning
well i woke up i immediately had a
protein shake
i've been experimenting with oats and
whey
eating experimenting with oats and whey
i was trying to avoid synthetic
maltodextrin which is derived from corn
and i had uh read that oats is a good
source of complex carbohydrates when
mixed with whey
can i ask you a quick question are you
wearing your sunglasses while you're
making the shake
are you looking to remove them what do
you think would be the human thing
you studied humans on our planet for a
while it makes you more comfortable
okay you got up you had your whey and
oat
shake then what uh then i prepared my
body
in various ways i cleaned it
i shaved it and uh
what do you mean okay i want to make it
very clear to everyone at home
this has come really happening this is
completely real this isn't scripted
you just said all those things this is a
real person
you're sick of people asking me how did
you find that guy who writes his stuff
you just said that you just said i
prepare my body in various ways
did you say you shaved it i did shave it
remove your shirt
please if you don't mind
so this is freshly shaved this area uh
no i didn't say i shaved my chest
i didn't settle i shaved my entire body
what part of your body did you shave
my face oh just your face oh
you saved down below gone south i
believe that's a private matter
you just took your shirt off i just
asked you if you shaved your your
your john dory do you matter
you draw the line there in terms of
talking about my daily grooming rituals
yes yes okay you can put your shirt back
on wait a minute
put the sunglasses on but leave the
shirt off
[Applause]
can i ask you why you have this instead
of just a regular packet of pepper
that's a pepper mill yeah i've never
seen anything like this before why is it
so small
it allows me to use fresh pepper on the
food that i eat without taking up an
inordinate amount of
death space right because you wouldn't
want to clutter
your space why do you have these
they were sent to me by who by a woman
that i know
a woman sent you these correct
the very definition of having this is
proof that you don't know a woman
you're not making eye contact with me
is your intention to hang on to these or
to give them to a worthy children's
charity
undecided
i'd like to help you be on time from now
on i think that that would be good for
you so we have some devices that might
help
would this be helpful to you this clock
i don't see how you could have this at
home and it would tell you what time it
is
and then you would know i should
probably get to work my lack of
awareness of the time
is not responsible for the hour that i
arrive in the office i'd like you to
hang this one in the office
and i'd like you to strap this one to
your vespa
it will be sort of the italian douchebag
flava flav
i also want you to know that you're
being monitored at all times by this
camera
i will constantly be monitoring that
camera to make sure
that one of my workers is a real busy
bee
buzz buzz this is a good old-fashioned
time card you are to punch in
and punch out every day i've had this
machine brought back would you like to
check in yes
i don't think the device works try again
you have to put it in the very center
you know how i knew it was the very
center no i've worked for a living
and gentlemen
uh it's so nice to see you it's been 15
months and it's really this is the first
time i'm seeing you in 15 months
it's good it's good to see you thank you
i've tried to remain of
sound minds and body uh it's good to see
you as well yeah you look well
all right all right for you that was
very good
uh i say enough with the chit chat
because i know from experience it won't
go far and i won't get much
jordan i've brought you out here for a
reason
okay the reason i brought you out is i
am not leaving
this theater until you tell me one thing
the question that has bedeviled me for
many many years
okay the question which i honestly
honestly don't know the answer to and
i'm being
so honest with you right now what do you
do for my show uh i have an assortment
of tasks in response no no
no no no no no no no that is you've done
that every time i am your boss
i sign your paychecks you are going to
tell me
what you do and why i pay you you pay me
to complete the tasks that are assigned
no no
i know it's all funny games
but that's not my attitude i'm not
kidding it's been 26 years
26 years i've paid you a lot of money
i've kept you in lattes and vespas and
johnny cash knockoff shirts
you owe it to me to tell me what you do
on the show first of all the plural of
latte is la ti
secondly do you even want to know what i
do on the show because there's been this
ongoing situation where you supposedly
don't understand what i do
i don't i really don't and if that's
true that's your fault not my fault
it's not my responsibility to disclose
what i do
nevertheless if you would like me to
bore everybody by enumerating the things
that i do on the show i am happy to do
that yes
yes
jordan go ahead and tell us what the
[ __ ] you do
on the show okay so basically on a daily
basis first
this is cnn breaking news
good evening i'm jake tapper and we're
interrupting this broadcast for some
important breaking news two weeks ago at
the detroit grand prix
a squirrel dramatically cheated death
when it jumped out of the path of a
speeding indycar
as you can see from this non-exclusive
footage the squirrel leapt out of harm's
way
at the last possible second the squirrel
is fine but we'll keep you updated if
its condition
changes i'm jake tapper we now return to
your regularly scheduled program
this is cnn breaking news it's basically
what i do
okay i get it now thank you jordan
incredible
no both both come on yeah
we have an amazing show seth rogen is
[Applause]
here